So it seems like a good idea and
I think it's worth asking whether or
not it actually works.
>> Does it work?
>> Well, it's complicated.
>> Tell me more.
>> There have been some examples where
things worked out extremely well.
So let me just quickly summarize
some of them, so you have a sense.
You mentioned neural networks, so neural
networks, including with non-linear
connections, have been used with
backpropagation in this context.
Folks like Gerry Tesauro and Tom
Dietterich have gotten some very nice
results creating learning
systems that can actually
do some fairly complicated things and
some difficult tasks.
>> Like what?
>> Well Gerry Tesauro's
work was in Backgammon, and
he actually used the same
kind of approach in
Jeopardy in the Watson system, for
figuring out how to do decision-making.
What's the right strategy for handling
different situations in jeopardy, and
the value function was being
predicted using a backprop net.
In Wang/Dietterich's work, they were
actually predicting the likelihood of
success of various sort of
shuttle scheduling strategies.
They were actually doing for
NASA shuttle scheduling strategies.
>> Say that three times fast.
>> She sells seashells to
the shuttling scheduling system.
>> Sure.
>> So those worked out really well.
That being said,
there's not that many other people
who've gotten that to work effectively.
Certainly, whenever, I'd say to my
students, look these things worked so
well, why don't you try it?
They don't seem to be nearly as
successful as these folks have been.
>> Hey, I got it to work for
my master's thesis.
>> Did you really?
For what problem?
>> For tic-tac-toe and then for
a vision problem that,
after I went through all this trouble,
I realized was just [INAUDIBLE] around.
>> [LAUGH],
that's impressive, in quotes.
>> Not impressive enough to
give me a master's thesis,
which I think was the important thing.
So maybe the impressive thing, is that
I got a master's thesis out of this.
[LAUGH]
>> At MIT, of all places.
>> Of all places.
>> So it does sometimes work.
I find that it's kind of difficult
to get it to work consistently.
What happens often, when my students try
this, is they get a system that actually
tends to start to learn well and then it
goes into some kind of a death spiral.
Because, as I mentioned before,
the bootstrapping aspect of this
means that you're really dependent on
making solid predictions based
on your previous predictions.
And when they start to go south,
the whole thing can fall apart
actually really quickly.
That being said,
there's some other function
approximators that actually have been
more successful that are variations
of linear function approximators.
So Rich Sutton, in particular,
has gotten CMAC to work on a on
a whole bunch of tough problems.
CMACs are c-m-a-c, it's a particular
kind of function representation that
is like a neural net, except
the first layer isn't really learned.
It's kind of decided in advance
how you're going to break up
the input space.
And so it really is just
a generalization of straight up linear.
These can be really effective, but they
don't generalize very aggressively and
that's part of what makes them
a bit safer to use in this setting.